vamos a pensar que significa multiplicar
un medio por
5 y podemos pensar esto de dos maneras
una manera es pensar que tenemos un
medio sumado cinco veces dos es decir
que esto es igual a un medio
más medio
más un medio
más
un medio más
un medio ahí tenemos un medio cinco
veces y esto es igual a la suma de estos
51 medios y esto es igual
uno más uno más uno más uno más uno
cinco veces entre
2 y esto es lo mismo que 5
medios
la otra manera de pensarlo es que
empezamos con cinco cosas una cosa
dos cosas
tres cosas
cuatro cosas
y cinco cosas imaginemos que todas estas
cosas son iguales y lo que nos está
diciendo esta multiplicación es que
vamos a tomar la mitad de estas cinco
cosas es decir que tomaríamos más o
menos
hasta aquí ahora imaginemos y tomamos
todo esto
ahora imaginemos que dividimos cada cosa
a la mitad está la mitad está la mitad a
la mitad a la mitad y a la mitad
entonces en vez de ver esto como si
tuviéramos 5 cosas esto es lo mismo que
tener 10 medios de cosas así que esto es
lo mismo que 1 2 3 4 y 5
medios de cosas de los 10 medios que
teníamos tomamos 5 esto que acabamos de
hacer fue pensar que significa
multiplicar que significa multiplicar un
medio por 5 pero bueno ahora veamos cómo
es que se computa esto es decir cómo
efectuamos un medio
por 5 fíjate que esto lo podemos ver
como un medio por 5 entre 1 porque 51 es
lo mismo que 5 y aquí tenemos una
multiplicación de fracciones y las
multiplicaciones de fracciones se hacen
de manera directa es decir esto es igual
a 1 por 5 entre 2 por 1 y esto hay que
es igual bueno en el numerador tenemos 1
por 5 que es 5 y en el denominador
tenemos 2 x 1 que estos quedan 5 medios
entonces aquí tenemos dos enfoques uno
fue pensar que significa multiplicar un
medio por 5 y el otro fue entender cómo
es que esto se computa